[Music]
[Applause]
hey you guys
we're still alive yeah youtube is
[ __ ]
all right it is you youtube is [ __ ]
um they don't they don't actually send
notifications it does not work as
advertised
every time we stream i get a i get a um
i get a notification maybe like one
quarter of the time
i don't know what to tell you yeah i'm
just well i'm just like
i'm worried about because we had so much
trouble last night it says excellent
connection right now
but that doesn't really mean anything
does it because we found out
i think it's i think it was our provider
and it was saturday which is a real
busy time i kind of suspect yeah i mean
people were just streaming their [ __ ]
asses off i mean it's saturday night
nowadays you know people don't go out to
the [ __ ] clubs like they used to it's
[ __ ]
this shit's like a depressing talk it's
just [ __ ] up
man don't be in such a bad mood
yeah we're talking about life after
death yeah
yeah because remember i said last night
that i had some
i had some uh feelings about that show
i don't wanna i don't wanna [ __ ] on it
too much because like a couple of the
episodes were
interesting a lot of people didn't get
notifications louie says he always gets
a notification he didn't get one today
clay says he never gets notified
i just i don't understand it man [ __ ]
youtube
youtube um youtube eventually hopefully
hopefully youtube will become a thing of
the past and we'll [ __ ] go on a
platform that actually does what it's
supposed to do
we just tell people that you're
streaming to [ __ ]
uh let people [ __ ] comment in the
comment sections
uh let people find your [ __ ] material
at this earth it's just
i i don't they just throttle you i think
what it is is they're so big
partially they're dealing with [ __ ]
our algorithms they're trying to
push everybody towards their corporate
sponsors
is one two i don't think they i don't
think they can really handle the [ __ ]
workload because think about it that
must be a [ __ ] ton of data
all that [ __ ] video processes all at
the same time
and then you're keeping track of all
those conversations
yeah i mean it's a massive massive so
like
i said that's why i'm just i'm loath to
just blame i think it's probably just
the fact that there's so much data
you know the algorithms are not you know
are not perfect
so i just feel like you're gonna get
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a lot i
i think i think what it is is that
youtube's basically a monopoly and it's
trying to handle [ __ ] everybody's
[ __ ] cert
they need to have we need to look into
something like d live i don't know what
do
you
what do you guys think about another
service like d
live because evidently [ __ ] d live
runs pretty [ __ ] smooth and
maybe we could have a youtube show but
once a week we could do a d live show
you know or something like that i don't
know which would be the same thing
it's just on a more reliable platform i
don't think i don't think
from what i'm seeing nobody's getting
their notifications
you know what i mean why are we live
streaming if nobody gets the goddamn
notifications
see how mad i am people i'm [ __ ] mad
it makes you wonder
how much i wonder how much in super
chats we lose when
you know what i mean because there's
people don't even know that we're
streaming
well i think one thing though is that
everybody that comes i mean they know
when we stream because we always stream
at the same time so
i think that's a good thing well that's
our hardcore fans though
to grow your market you have to have a
reliable platform that tells people that
you exist
you know i think what i think what what
it looks like that they do is they let
you get a certain size and then they go
okay we're going to keep these people
small we don't want to pay them any more
than what they're making now
it's like that i think just say it
yeah i don't know like it's just saying
i um it seems to be going okay so far
um i re let's see i updated the obs like
the streaming program
i did a hard reboot i did a connection
you know thingy [ __ ] uh what do you
call it
troubleshooting and it said everything
was fine now the only thing that it said
that was going on with the laptop was
that
the uh ac adapter they said well the
battery's charging but it needs
recalibration
so i don't know if that would maybe just
unplug and plug it back in well yeah i
did that
you know we'll see how i don't know so
you have to run another like battery
check later on
you have to do it for you have to like
do it for three hours like you have to
plug it in for three hours and then you
have to
yeah last night was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] not only did we just get
hammered
they kept [ __ ] the stream up now we
got [ __ ] four five six pieces of
[ __ ]
video there and how are we going to edit
are we going to eventually edit that
into one
i might i might one of those 26 seconds
long
no it's not there's there's the shortest
one is five minutes
okay um some of them don't have much
content in them it's just asking what
the [ __ ] is what
then it disappears well i went in and
trimmed out like because sometimes like
the last few seconds would just be like
being like what the [ __ ] not again so
it's like i trim some of that off
now the audio version i edited it all
into one
and it ended up being like four and a
half hours long or something like that
but
i don't know i might eventually edit the
video one into one thing too but
i'll do it just some time later yeah
because it's just
but it takes so long and what happens if
you re-edit the video into one
video do you lose all your super chat
money no you don't lose them
no you don't lose the money no you might
lose the live chat
because you know because it's not in
that same format anymore
that's kind of the only reason i'm
reluctant to do it because
you know it's kind of nice to see
everyone's like comments and stuff over
on the side
but i feel like if you if you download
them all and edit them together you're
going to lose that because that's like a
different format
you know the live chat isn't there once
it once it posts
it goes into just regular um comments
oh on mine it has it has live chat
replay yeah really mine doesn't it
doesn't have it on my device
well maybe it's just because that's i
mean on my uh
on my laptop and on my desktop yeah it
has live chat replay
it's a that might be a setting that you
can change i'm not really sure
um we got 13 in there nobody's talking
you all ain't saying [ __ ] so
let's go ahead it still says we're on
and it looks like we're on and it's not
even that far behind so maybe
yeah maybe last night we were just
getting like connection problems because
i feel like maybe our wi-fi was [ __ ]
up or some [ __ ] like that all right
i got some [ __ ] cough drops
yeah i tried to eat a sandwich today my
[ __ ]
nose is so [ __ ] up that everything
smells like
smells terrible smells like i got a damn
forest fire in my nose
that's a bummer yeah i tried to eat a
sandwich that i cooked barbecue sandwich
and it smelled so bad
because of this [ __ ] [ __ ] i was like
i couldn't eat it i could i could only
eat hard-boiled eggs
she was terrible that vinegar smelled
like [ __ ] rotten plastic
yeah yeah well um
yeah you might have some kind of i i
have a little bit of it too i just
noticed because i started uh
i started coughing a little bit last
night i don't feel too bad i'm real cold
and i'm just coughing a bit but that's
about it yeah
sandra says on her laptop she didn't see
the live chat either once the show's
over oh i do
that's just something that that's just
you on your [ __ ]
it's just me it's just me because i'm
[ __ ] special you that you have that
special deluxe
internet service [ __ ] yeah that's right
yeah
all right so let's talk about this
[ __ ] show can we do that yeah go
ahead we're gonna talk about it
don't sound so enthusiastic okay so this
is a six-episode
docu-series that just dropped on netflix
and it's called surviving death i guess
it's based on
this book by a journalist i think her
name's leslie keane
so basically what they did was each
episode
focuses on a different thing so like the
first one is near death experiences
the second and third one i don't know
why they needed two episodes going into
this because they're like an hour long
are about like physical mediums and
seances and [ __ ] which i'm just like
okay whatever
and then the fourth one was i think um
like signs from the dead like people
that said that they got science from it
i think there was an apparitions one
and then i think there was a
rancarnation one right that seems like
the ones that they were
so we tried because you know tom is like
oh man we need to watch that because
that looks like really cool now the
first episode which is about near death
excuse me near death experiences was
actually um
pretty interesting and the people that
they had on there that had like their
stories were actually pretty
interesting because the thing about
near-death experiences is that
that's kind of i guess you could call it
paranormal but that's something that
you could have scientific proof of that
you know what i mean or you know
proof of it that makes it more likely so
i think in that
sense they should have stuck more with
science kind of [ __ ] rather than going
off into like
medium kind of [ __ ] yeah out of the
whole series that first episode
about the near-death experiences i was
[ __ ] right there with it i was like
yeah
that's what happened to me yeah and a
near-death experience and a
and a [ __ ] spontaneous out-of-body
experience which i've had that also
um and uh
you know what i mean [ __ ] what what
they're saying is exactly
what the experience was like for me and
what's funny is that
in one case the woman had
the out-of-body experience or was it the
near-death experience and there was
something retroactive about it or she
she predicted the death of her yes i was
just gonna talk about that one so this
woman
i think this was the first woman that
they talked to she was um
what do you call it kayaking and she
went off a [ __ ]
waterfall that she didn't mean to go
down
obviously and pretty much she was kind
of crushed like underneath the boat and
she was like drowning and stuff
and she was talking about the experience
that she knew that she was dying but she
didn't feel any pain she wasn't scared
or anything like that
and she was under there holy [ __ ] man
how how long was she under the water 20
minutes
it was a long time it was a long time um
i don't know how cold the water was
because that was the first thing i asked
so i imagine it's probably pretty cold
so finally her friends who had been
looking for and after a while they were
just like look man we can't find her
we're just gonna have to leave her there
but then like they saw her boat and then
they saw her body floating by
and they said when they picked up her
body like she was very clearly dead she
wasn't like kind of bloated and like
[ __ ] like that
but they somehow got her up to the thing
and she
came back to life and she actually even
though she was all busted up
obviously because she went off a [ __ ]
tall waterfall she actually made a full
recovery no brain damage
no nothing but the weird thing is that
she said
that when she was in the near-death
experience which sounded very similar to
the one that you had
where they were just like these beings
who
knew her but she didn't quite like know
who they were but they were like still
familiar
yeah yeah and they told her that her son
was going to die they didn't say when
um but they said that she was gonna that
and she said that
she got the um impression that her son
was gonna die before he was 18
and she was like wigging out about it
and she's like and i never told him
you know until after he had turned 18
because i thought he was safe
then and then like a year or two later
he died like in an accident
yeah creepy that's pretty creepy
yeah but uh out of the whole series you
want to watch that that first one i can
attest
to what they're saying there i can back
that up so yeah that's what it was like
to me
um they even had some doctors as
witnesses one of them was it had it
happened to her and she was a doctor
um talked about her near-death
experience
that she was a doctor when it drowned
wasn't it i think she might have been
she was a doctor
and then there was another um situation
where
they were working on some woman and she
left her body
in some kind of out-of-body experience
and she could hear everything the
doctors were saying
and could describe what the hell was
going on and was watching them and she
could play back the entire operation
even though she had stuff over her eyes
and ears yeah and then
and at the time they had her hooked up
to an ekg machine
there was no brain activity right they
put on an induced coma right i think
that's what that's actually
you don't need brain activity to have
this out of body experience
you're freed from it i talk about it in
uh
mountain poltergeist what it was like
for me and what was weird
in my case is i had a spontaneous out of
body experience
a few weeks before of a [ __ ]
near-death experience in a motorcycle
accident
and it was kind of like almost that the
ni that the
the the obe and the near-death
experience were the same
kind of like part of the same phenomenon
that's like
it's like i like i had an out-of-body
experience
because i didn't have much time left to
live
right you know what i mean almost like
training for it maybe
but it turns out i did live yeah it was
weird
because she said that some of the stuff
that she had was kind of like
retroactive it's outside
the normal time space-time continuum
yeah
it's just weird [ __ ] and then
one guy described that when he uh
exteriorized he was touching
leaves and stuff and becoming part of
the leaves and becoming immersed
and that's exactly what it was like yeah
he got like electrocuted didn't he
i think like in a bucket truck i looked
at the wall locker and saw
inside the wall locker inside the the
particle board of the wall locker
looked like [ __ ] sick blue cigarette
smoke just [ __ ]
swirling atoms and then you kind of kind
of like
went inside of it and it like i got
small and went in there and then [ __ ]
back back out of it
and could see what the contents of what
was inside the wall locker
and it wasn't any kind of color it was
just it was
all the colors at once and then i could
see
objects from two opposing points of view
at the same time like i could see it
looking down on it and then another and
another point of view of looking up on
it
at the same time being in and it felt
like being in two places
at the same time you're kind of like
non-local
you know or yeah and that seems to be
like what people are
not everybody i mean some people that
have they didn't go a lot into this but
some people
i mean just kind of this show that we
did about out of body experiences
a lot of people have either no
experience at all or they have something
negative
so they did kind of mention that but i
think they kind of went with
um you know kind of more positive things
but um there was one two where
wasn't there one there was she was the
pregnant woman and this was where
this was real weird too because she had
um i think it was her second kid she was
pregnant with her second kid
and she was became convinced
that she had uh what do they call that
pla uh [ __ ]
previa whatever it's called where um you
know so
you'll bleed to death you know usually
and she was
you know a few months into the pregnancy
she was just adamant that that was gonna
happen to her and that she was gonna die
and her husband of course was like
[ __ ] you're just being a hysterical
pregnant woman
whatever but then when she went into
labor
like she did and she did die but she had
um
she like went out and she could describe
like all the [ __ ] in the room and
exactly what happened and all the
instruments and all that other kind of
[ __ ] too um
and then her husband who seemed like
kind of a schmuck to be honest with you
but um
i don't know he just had he can be like
a little dick vibe
but he was just kind of like yeah i
guess there was something to it after
all
it was kind of like that but i think i
mean that show
was the most interesting to me because
that seems like
[ __ ] that you can you know prove
kind of i mean you can do because i
remember i read this book a long time
ago if you guys haven't read it i think
it's called um what the [ __ ] is the name
of that woman
it's over there somewhere it's called
spook and it's called science
tackles the afterlife and it's kind of
it's this journalist and she goes all
around
to different places where they're
studying different near-death
experiences and all that other kind of
stuff
and it's really really interesting it's
funny too but it's you know she actually
does
talk to like real doctors that are
looking into this stuff and one of the
most clever
um experiments that they did with that
was that they would put
they would they would make like stickers
with words on them and stuff and they
would put them they would put them like
up on top of really tall like [ __ ]
file cabinets and [ __ ] like that
and they had like really weird words and
shapes and stuff up there so that if
anybody exteriorized they would ask them
afterwards like if they were dead if
they had been able to see them
yeah which um like i said that doesn't
prove it prove it but
it does it you know it is kind of um you
know a lot of evidence in that regard
it's just a weird experience you know
i was riding the motorcycle and i don't
even really remember the
you know i don't i don't remember the
accident yeah i was just riding
i was heading towards the the uh
intersection where the accident happened
and i looked down or the way i
remembered is i looked down and saw my
shadow
on the ground of me riding the
motorcycle and then all of a sudden i
realized not i wasn't just looking at
the shadow
and i was looking at myself riding the
motor right in the motorcycle
and i was like where's that light coming
from it was like some kind of shadow and
turned around and looked
and it was a big old ball of white light
came down and got me
and then i was just in another realm and
they had these
six or seven people that i knew came
down to greet me and they kind of looked
it looked like a um it looked like a an
entire universe
made out of prismatic welding arc you
know the [ __ ] white yeah
that's what it looked like and um
it was in every direction at once and
when they came to me they would kind of
formed from that prismatic energy
and they kind of formed into avatars of
who they were
yeah and it was um they looked like
i guess you could say the artistic style
is that they look like those greco-roman
statues
oh okay yeah you know what i mean like
like the funerary statues from
from the savannah georgia um
cemetery yeah that's what they kind of
look like um
they had that same architectural style
and um when they spoke it's kind of like
they got closer
and it wasn't sound it was
kind of like direct thought transmission
and imagery
but i could hear the voice too and the
emotion behind it which is crazy there
was
i know there wasn't any sound and then
the background was just
like this musical
[ __ ] kind of like angelic glorious
kind of [ __ ] i don't know singing in
music
going on in the background it's like
straight out of [ __ ] the pearly gates
and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and i remember them i knew who they were
but i i couldn't tell you who they were
there was something from the distant
past
past lives stuff that's the same thing
that woman said she said they seemed
familiar but i couldn't tell you
they were they knew who i was yeah and i
knew who they were at the time that they
were talking to me
right but after it was all done
uh they said that i wasn't going to be
allowed to remember
everything they said that yeah so i
think a lot of it was kind of
or that i wouldn't or wasn't allowed to
remember anything i don't
one of the two and didn't you say they
kind of told you that you couldn't go
yet because you still had [ __ ] today
or something yeah some things they
showed me certain things that were going
to happen
good and bad and a lot of it did happen
yeah see that's the same thing that you
wouldn't have they told her that are
somebody's gonna die yeah it's kind of
private so i won't talk about it but
like everything is uh your life is like
part of a [ __ ] thread instead of a
tapestry and it's all kind of [ __ ] or
kind of a carpet or something and it's
all kind of woven together to make a
creation
like that climb barker book weave world
that was called yeah
that was kind of kind of the premise of
so that have to do a bunch of stuff in
order to make something happen
and it seems very profound at the time
you're being told this or shown this
but i would probably put it on par with
like [ __ ] really good acid trip where
it seems really profound at the time
but then when you come back to normal
reality you're like is that what it was
just that it seems like it's more
profound when you're being told
yeah and they have done actual studies
of people and they said that
most of the um most of the near-death
experiences
that people report are very very similar
to the effects of like dmt
yeah um so it's it's the same [ __ ]
that's triggering in your brain
obviously
yeah they were talking to me one of them
one of them was
the face facial structure looked just
like olivia you know our friend olivia
yeah she's kind of mixed she looked like
that but she had
straight hair and she had a cow a hood
over her head and she was little
and um a headband
she looked like some kind of a
ancient tribal
priestess or something yeah and i just
it was she was some kind of wise figure
from the past
i knew who it was right but i couldn't
tell you who it was
she she told me a bunch of stuff and
there were some guys there too who i
knew they were
but i didn't spend that much time
talking to them now i don't know
exactly what the deal was are these
anxious ancestors
are they people that you knew in past
lives are they you
your avatars from past lives i don't
know
yeah it could have been that too they
could have been like yeah there's lots
of possibilities
right louie said tom was your experience
before you met
me yeah it was yeah long time ago it was
a long time one was back in the 90s
right
yeah that was like a 94. yeah so that
was a long time ago because we didn't
meet until 2010 maybe yeah
something like that um yeah so i do kind
of want to talk about so that was
the best episode by far like the
reincarnation one was kind of
interesting too even though i'm not sure
i buy reincarnation but some of this
[ __ ] i was like oh that's pretty creepy
but like the other ones like i said i
don't understand
it seemed like they made two episodes
about
the mediums and the oh thanks and the um
you know uh the physical mediums like
you know that kind of [ __ ] the seances
and whatnot it seemed like they were
just trying to stretch it out to six
episodes it's like they could have just
had five
easily because here's what they did like
the second episode kind of focused a lot
on i guess there's this kind of new agey
like physical mediumship training kind
of thing it's in the netherlands
and they went there and they were
talking to this one woman i can't what
was her name nicole de haas or something
like that and she's like a physical
medium which means
you know ectoplasm and all that kind of
[ __ ] where it's not necessarily
ectoplasm but
they can well they say they can you know
manifest like physical things like we're
in the thing
so they build this whole thing up um
about you know these are all my people
and i don't know like all the new age
terminology they used because i just
kind of started rolling my eyes and like
started like reading something else
but um because you know i kind of just
my eyes started glazing over it that
kind of stuff
but it was the whole thing where they're
all sitting around in a dark room they
put her in the box and like they
zip tie her to the chair and all this
other kind of stuff
and then they they build it up like to
then to the second episode then they're
like ooh cliffhanger
and i'm like [ __ ] i better see some
ectoplasm at the beginning of this third
one because i'm
i sat through this [ __ ] for this and
then at the beginning of the third one
they were just kind of like oh well by
the way
um we don't allow cameras inside the
seances so we don't allow them to be
filmed
and it's completely dark it's completely
black in there
all they do is record the audio i'm like
what the [ __ ] good is that
and it's like they pull her out of the
box and it's like oh she had like a
little dribble of some [ __ ] on her
she's like come on knock it off same old
tricks they've been playing yeah
the 1800s like that shit's been debunked
for hundreds of years
let me answer some questions um
business want to know how sharp is your
awareness when all this is going on
in a near-death experience it's you're
kind of like experiencing um
kind of like uh hyper reality it seems
like it's more real
than this reality when you're there
looking back at this reality this is
more like an illusion and
that is more real than it um
there's like a [ __ ] fantastic sense
of
of liberation that you can do anything
or go
anywhere or be anything um
that you've kind of returned home um
you're like nah nah i don't want to go
back it's that kind of thing you know
like not
it sounds stereotypical but that's
that's what's left yeah because that's
that one that's what that one guy said
too because he saw his dad who he had
had like kind of a
you know relationship with and he saw
him at the end and got to hug him and
stuff and he's like man you can't stay
here
and he was like no i want to stay
because it was awesome but
they're like no you have to go back and
when i turned i turned away from them
i remember turning away from them and it
changed
it went from that 360 degree welding arc
universe
with [ __ ] kind of like greek statues
talking to you
they didn't move that much that's the
weird thing there wasn't a lot of detail
in them
they were just kind of like avatars
i turned away from them and it looked
and then just saw the blackness of space
or kind of like the blackness of space
just
nothingness a void and
in the void at an angle i saw a disc
a big flat disc and it was all the color
it was it was
a bunch of colors and a bunch of [ __ ]
weird patterns
and i realized that what i was looking
at was past
present and future of the [ __ ]
physical universe
and i saw where i belonged and i zoomed
in in there and bam i was back
but that's what it looked like that's
how it was represented that's pretty
crazy yeah
turn around there it was and it kind of
reminded me of
kind of reminded me of a [ __ ] in a
way you know like the the [ __ ] wheel
that you spin from the wheel of fortune
kind of like that but yeah i remember
you telling me that yeah it's kind of
like that
and that's how big it seemed to me at
the time you're like yeah i'm gonna buy
a valve
but it was real [ __ ] um
cool looking and it was kind of like
interwoven almost like an oriental rug
it was weird
yeah i get what you're saying it was a
bunch of [ __ ]
timelines and places past present and
future
kind of was being represented in all of
space it was kind of
being represented as a singularity that
you could see it all at the same time
you had to figure out and it kind of
instinctively went back where it was
supposed to be
that's what it looked like glowing
turtle says any supernatural or creepy
stories from your time in the military
that was when i was in the military yeah
yeah and then
i had the out-of-body experience about a
week or so before i had that one the
out-of-body experience was cool too but
i talked about that in the book yeah
louis says did you wake up at the scene
of the accident of the hospital
yeah you were out i was in i was at
walter reed army hospital like a week
later yeah because you'd been at coma
yeah i did it
yeah so um yeah so i wanted to say to
you that like i said
so then they kind of had all that
bullshitty [ __ ] going on and then
they talked to a bunch of mediums and it
kind of
just it was kind of like this dude and
he seemed like kind of skeptical and
stuff but he was kind of going around
all these different mediums because he
wanted to talk to his dad because he
loved his dad very much and
he felt like you know his dad died very
suddenly and so he was trying to contact
him
so he goes around to all of these
mediums and
all of them suck ass i mean seriously i
mean i do
like they were kind of sympathetic
toward the mediums which kind of pissed
me off honestly because a lot of them
just really weren't doing a very good
job
but i liked that they did show one i
don't know if this is what they intended
but they did show one of them talking to
this other guy who was also trying to
contact his dad who had died when he was
a kid
and this uh this [ __ ] psychic
was just eating [ __ ] although he didn't
get a single thing right
um he kept saying it's your grandfather
he kept saying like he got every single
thing wrong
and he was doing so badly that even he
realized it and it was just like really
really awkward
and like finally he was just like yeah
i'm just not getting anything today i'm
like
the hell you're not um but it's sad
because like the dude that was doing the
sitting
because i think somebody mentioned this
up here i think when you go to a psychic
i don't think people realize how much
information you're giving to that person
and it's like every time they show
people doing it and they're sitting for
these readings
and you know the psychic does like the
regular psychic [ __ ] like
oh i'm seeing a you know something with
a k or blah blah blah
somebody will perk up and they'll say
the person's name
i'm like you just gave them information
that they didn't have before
and then later on they'll like say oh
they knew the person's name no they
didn't
you told them it yeah and so every time
that happened i was just like shut up
shut up but yeah so those two were like
really bullshitty and like we weren't
even going to
i think we started watching we watched
the first medium one and i was like oh
god there's another one of these and
then i just went and watched [ __ ]
masterchef but um we was like well we'll
finish the series because
because maybe it gets better and like we
wanted to review it the reincarnation
one was kind of interesting
um because i did like all i do like i
don't like i said i don't know if i buy
it or not but i do like all those kind
of creepy stories of like kids saying
like really creepy [ __ ] like you know
this is where i died and all that [ __ ]
you know i love that kind of [ __ ] i
don't know if it's real but i think it's
creepy
there could be a couple different
explanations for that though that's true
genetic memories or maybe yeah i don't
know
um i gotta answer a question uh that was
from bee's nest
you want to know how long it seems to
take place all right
the the spontaneous outer body
experience that i had
when i was in the barracks and the and
the near-death experience
they kind of like i guess you could say
the rhythm of them
is time wise it seemed it seemed they
seemed very different
the outer body experience i know that
that only took place
because there was a witness to it that
was only a couple minutes
but while i was out it seemed like it
was as long as i wanted it to be i made
a bunch of different
observations and [ __ ] detected a
bunch of [ __ ]
and i uh [ __ ] um made all kinds of
[ __ ] mental judgments
on the situation it seemed like it would
i i did enough stuff in those
maybe like two minutes i did enough
stuff that would have been
it would take like [ __ ] 15 minutes to
do yeah
you know what i mean it felt like that
although i know it was only two minutes
it's just that you're not as limited so
you can
think faster and do more stuff in a
smaller amount of time
and it's like you have a lot more time
in the
you know to work with it's what it felt
like yeah
in the near death experience i know i
was i was out for like
four or five days
but the whole experience kind of felt
like
you know the the whole [ __ ] seeing
the light and [ __ ] going dealing with
these people and then going coming back
to the physical
realm that only seemed to be like
it's hard to say because i'm leaving
some of it out
when i looked down on the ground and saw
my shadow
and then realized i was looking at
myself look at the shadow i
kind of had a quick little life review
what was like man i had a good life for
this and that and then
went then you know what i mean yeah
so i did a lot of stuff in a very short
period of time
in some ways time really was kind of
meaningless
i think somebody else on that um nde
show said the same a similar
thing where it's like they where time
didn't really seem to matter it was just
like very
it's real fluid yeah um but
i would say
the near-death experience at price it
seemed like
it all took place in about three or four
minutes
like three or four minutes but i got a
lot done during that three or four
minutes
but i was out for like five days yeah
louie asked what's it like to be in a
coma
well like i said you know man [ __ ]
like i
came to five days later some [ __ ]
cute army nurse
chick pulling a catheter out of my
[ __ ] jump
i grabbed her like that and she was
looking at me surprised because i had
come out of it
yeah she pulled that's what i don't
think you've ever seen that before
yeah maybe that's why my head is still
[ __ ] swelled up about the size of a
damn basketball
yeah yeah because you busted your head
off yeah
you're wearing a helmet but it came on
we came off here and all that yeah i had
it on i was just running up the street
i had it on but i didn't [ __ ] strap
it
and what did we learn
[Laughter]
but yeah so and like i said there was
one there was another one that was
kind of bullshitty too that was like
signs from the dead which is like people
that
the thing about that one that kind of
annoyed me it's like i don't want to
it's like i don't want to [ __ ] on the
people on there because they all seemed
like lovely people and they had all
you know they were all grieving they had
lost their loved ones and you can
understand
why um you know thank you mango
small flashbulb for tonight's show and
laughs we'll become infamous and legend
yeah i know right
[ __ ] shit's shutting down all the
time so it's like so i don't really want
to like
you know piss on their parade too much
but
some of the things that they consider
as you know signs from their loved one
i'm like i
kind of feel like i would need a little
something more than that you know what
i'm saying
it's like oh i found a penny on my floor
that was you know the date
that like some psychic told me that you
know he'll give me dimes
and then like i found a dime like on my
bedroom floor that had like the date of
his birth on i'm like
okay but i feel like
if you're gonna get if you're gonna give
me a sign from the other side then it
better be something [ __ ]
unequivocal you know what i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
i feel like we should do like houdini
and his wife did
where they had uh they had a code set up
and only they knew it
because he because he didn't believe it
but he wanted to believe it
like i said so they had set up this
thing they're like okay if you die first
this is the message that we're gonna
give to each other and they never got it
yeah well that's because that [ __ ]
never had a [ __ ] near-death
experience it'd be hard to do that
um somebody's asking me
if i think there's an afterlife says
yeah i think there's an afterlife adam
before
life the problem is is that and the
reason why
houdini did wasn't able to bring the
damn message back
to resist the pull of it you know what i
mean would be like
being a really bad heroin addict and
trying to coming out of the [ __ ] the
hair you know yeah like
you you you don't want to come back yeah
all right
and then i have a feeling that if you're
there for too long
your old identity from your last life
starts to fall away because that's not
really you
what you end up being is more just like
a point of view
yeah you know what i mean a point of
perception yes
just like your little consciousness just
yeah you're not real
super intelligent you're like a little
squirrel-like creature that just
can see [ __ ] and can go around and then
you can
become something if you want to in the
physical realm you can become whatever
you want
that's what it seemed like sheila ann
said i just got here how did you wind up
in a coma
motorcycle motorcycle and um how's your
cough
yeah it's getting worse the um yeah
there's also
there's a bunch of stuff that happened
in the in in
um now this is some weird [ __ ] jenny
really
she doesn't come from a background of
this she doesn't really buy into it even
though i've showed her
just the tip of the iceberg with [ __ ]
worn out old [ __ ] poultry guy stuff
i was a lot better at it when i was
looking like 12 13 15 but
it's it's real but it's kind of like
cheating you're not really allowed to do
it
you're not supposed to be doing it but
it can happen um
when i was having that when i had the
out of body experience i came away
there's a lot of other frequencies it
sounds ridiculous but there's like
higher frequencies and low
higher energy frequencies and lower
energy frequencies
it's kind of like a radio dial
if you start going down real low on the
dial
you end up in these real slow kinda
low energy
realms all right you could probably
describe them as
as hells but what's down there
is just like uh bad emotions
of real simple type
astral creatures that's the only way i
can describe them kind of like the
astral version of insects and bugs and
animals and if you keep going up higher
you can start going into very high
realms where you're going to deal with
eventually [ __ ] like angelic beings and
i i was under the impression and i was
i was fighting this pull upwards
like i was being pulled upwards into
these higher realms
and i had not died i was just in bed
and during that time there was an
outburst of
spontaneous psychokinesis the guys in
the barracks saw it happen
i tell a whole story in math mountain
poultry it's pretty creepy
yeah and um he saw that
which is that's good because um i wasn't
sure if if a person could actually see
it
he's not yeah and um
i was fighting this urge to be pulled up
in these higher realms and i was under
the impression
that if i allowed that to happen that i
wouldn't be able to come back
yeah so i was trying to stabilize more
in the
in into what you would call the physical
realm
here but it looks very different from
when you're exteriorized this
physical realm looks very different than
it does when you're looking at it
through eyes
yeah there's a really i mean you gave
like a really good description of that
[ __ ] like in the book and everything
looks like
and you might have talked about it when
we did the out-of-body experiences yeah
it looks like it's made out of energy
it looks like if you rub your eyes and
you see a bunch of colors that's what it
looks like you see the shapes of things
but you don't have to be in one place at
the time you could be in two places at
the same time or you can be spread out
over a general area
i was about the size of a ping-pong ball
most of the time
um you can see 360 degrees
if you look too closely at something
you'll get smaller and go into it
uh when you first come out you have a
hard time standing still you want to be
moving in every direction you're looking
at
so it took it took a few seconds or at
least it seemed like it took a few
seconds it's probably a
millisecond because it's hard to tell
how time is flowing
yeah it was like uh i couldn't look at
anything without
go [ __ ] go into it yeah so it was
kind of like i was balanced on a
pogo stick or something but then that
settled down
and i was just kind of this it was weird
it does sound like a really rare and
then you say too that most of the room
looked
the same like most of the furniture was
there but the colors were different
and then you said that there were some
shapes in there like [ __ ] like some
pyramids and yeah
yeah there were geometrical shapes in
the room that weren't in in the room but
i kind of chose not to see him and they
faded away
and then um davis was in the room with
me and i could see him but he just
looked like a black
shadow and it looked like he was
blocking out
the environment behind him that's not
the only way i can describe he looks
two-dimensional kind of
yeah it looked kind of like a paper cut
out yeah and and uh when he moved he
looked real
fluid almost kind of like a black cloud
and when he stopped
or paused then i could see the arms and
legs but when he moved it just became
kind of like an amorphous blob
because he was freaking out right yeah
and i could hear him
but it was like i could hear him from
far away it was weird
yeah glowing turtle says you turned into
an orb yeah basically
pretty much yeah because you're like
yeah you always say that you feel like
you were like
he could see it but he wouldn't tell me
what it looked like yeah because it
freaked him out like i thought he wanted
to beat my ass over it
he did he said he i contacted him on
facebook he wouldn't talk to me
yeah yeah yeah he says don't you ever
[ __ ] talk about this don't you ever
[ __ ] talk about this
yep what was that what was that
yeah i think he thought it was like some
weird satanic or sorcery
i don't know but yeah so like i said
um it's worth watching like i said if
you're gonna watch it i would recommend
just watching the first one about ndes
which that's kind of interesting
and like i said the reincarnation one is
interesting too just you know in a
creepy
you know kids say the creepiest things
kind of way like that's kind of cool
but the other ones i think i probably
could have done without
they were just we did watch all of them
but yeah
you know they didn't really they didn't
really present any compelling evidence
for any of their claims
and it mostly was just like a bunch of
kind of new agey stuff which i don't
really have a lot of patience for him
you know
but uh yeah so you have anything else
you would like to add
i guess that's about it we've been going
almost an hour holy crap i thought i'd
be falling asleep before that because
i'm like worn out but and hey
the connection stayed the whole time yay
yeah
so it still says excellent connection
yeah so it must have just we must have
just had problems with our wi-fi last
night i can't really think of any other
season maybe we should reschedule and
try to avoid saturdays maybe it's too
busy
maybe everybody's trying to [ __ ]
stream off maybe like we never started
having
problems until the last couple weeks you
know i feel like we used to kind of we'd
go like three or four hours and we
wouldn't have any problems but then like
as soon as the jonestown won
we did the jones town with heaven's gate
one was fine it didn't um
that one didn't turn off but the
jonestown one
clicked off like one time about three
hours in i said there's another
dimension out there
that's why the unions take peyote yeah i
think i think there's something to that
the ayahuasca and stuff dmt but i think
that's kind of like a pay a limitation
because i've taken some of those and
it's like a pale limitation of the real
thing
it's uh it's related but
near death thank you focus on you thank
you very much orbs freaked me out i took
a selfie and an orb was in my pick see
that might have been somebody
that was exteriorizing from their body
you know
well you know you don't know yeah
altered states of consciousness can
put you in contact with certain but it
isn't just in one other dimension it's a
bunch of other ones
yeah it's a lot of them it's like a
multiverse of them
um it's like some of these guys
in advanced physics they're talking
about well there might be a multiverse
lots of different dimensions
but then guys who are a little more
conservative who also
have the same credentials they'll say
there's no evidence of any of that
some of that multiverse stuff when when
i exteriorized
i didn't see any of that yeah it was
just this universe and then once higher
and lower it had to do with kind of like
it's kind of like it's kind of like the
spectrum of light or radio frequencies
yeah you got a man that actually makes
sense it's more like that
and um the higher up it is
the less physical it is and the less
i guess you say in a way kind of like
the easier it is
and um the lower energy kind of like the
slower and the kind of the nastier it is
it's like that and um seems like our
universe is kind of like
somewhere in the middle of all that yeah
that
that stands to reason doesn't it but it
is i think it's
has something to do with uh like quantum
particles
it's like a quantum realm yeah you know
and it might seem like there's a lot
above and below in terms of [ __ ]
bandwidth but
probably not that much it probably just
seems like it's a lot
it's probably just quantum particles
floating around you know i mean
entertain or what they call it quantum
entanglement with the universe
and those quantum particles somehow kind
of give that effect
of there being higher and lower realms
and that there's consciousnesses in them
yeah especially the ones in the upper
ones the lower ones
like i was i was aware for a second
that something moved through the room
in another lower frequency and it was
just like a moving bubble
and it was it was really in nothing
like a fish but it wasn't a fish it was
just uh
yeah i get what you're saying you know
what i'm talking about something maybe
farther down
something down in the evolutionary scale
yeah it wasn't it wasn't threatening
it was just some kind of life form yeah
you know what
remember the [ __ ] remember uh um from
beyond
yeah with the with the president
resonator something like that
it felt like but they didn't look like
biological creatures they
yeah hp lovecraft knew what was up yeah
[Laughter]
so we will be back again tomorrow
talking about another movie
and now i'm gonna go take a goddamn nap
because i'm really really sleepy and you
need to go take some more cough drops
yeah and get better
and uh i probably do too like i said i
need a nap so uh
thanks everybody for dropping by and
we'll see you guys
again tomorrow